ليس هناك شك بين الدول الأعضاء
وفي سياق مجموعة
الدول الصناعية السبع الكبرى أننا بحاجة إلى التواصل مع طالبان
نحتاج للتأثير على طالبان
نحتاج إلى الاستفادة من الروافع المالية
التي لدينا ولكننا لن نتسرع في
الاعتراف  هذا التشكيل الجديد ولا في
إقامة علاقات رسمية
يجب أن يكون هناك خط مشروط صارم
مرتبط بإنفاذ
التزام طالبان بالسماح
بالمرور الحر لأولئك الأفغان الذين يرغبون في
المغادرة
وعدم الانتقام من
المنتسبين
لقوى أجنبية أو
الحكومة السابقة طالبان ولكننا نرى الحاجة إلى أن نكون
قادرين على المشاركة المباشرة وإلا
فلن نتمكن من
تقديم رسائل لا يمكننا الاستماع إلى
الرد وأعتقد
كما قال صديقي الشيخ محمد
أعتقد أن هناك بعض الاختبارات المبكرة لـ
كان طالبان واحد هو نهجهم في
المطار أثناء الإخلاء ، والآن نحن
في مساحة مختلفة ،
هل يمكننا أن نرى ممرًا آمنًا يتم توفيره
من أفغانستان من شأنه أن
يعد اختبارًا أولًا مهمًا جدًا نحتاج إلى أن نكون
قادرين على مناقشة ذلك أو الانخراط
فيه وستكون هناك قضايا أخرى
نريد جميعًا تجنب
وقوع كارثة أو أزمة إنسانية
بشكل جيد والتي ستتطلب من طالبان أن تكون
قادرة على
توفير وضمان السماح
المناخ والبيئة لعمال الإغاثة ،
لذلك أعتقد أن المشاركة ستكون
مهمة من أجل وضع اختبارات
مبكرة وما سنحكم على الطالبان من خلاله
هو أفعالهم وليس كلماتهم
علينا
أن ننتقد الذات ،
وعلينا إجراء
تقييم  الأسباب التي
تجعل مثل هذا الانهيار محتملاً ،
ما الخطأ الذي حدث
في هذه الفترة الطويلة من المشاركة مع
أفغانستان ، علينا تعلم دروس
لمواقف مماثلة
، وسيكون
هذا التقييم
الذي بدأ الآن
سيكون خلفية مناقشتنا
اليوم وأعتقد أنه  من الواضح أن الحاجة إلى
المزيد من الدفاع الأوروبي
لم تكن أبدًا بنفس القدر من
الوضوح اليوم
بعد الحدث في
أفغانستان وأنا متأكد من أن
الوزراء
سيناقشون حول كيفية مواجهة هذا  الوضع الجديد
كيف يمكننا أن نكون أكثر استعدادًا
للتحديات المستقبلية
نحن في أفغانستان
أم
[موسيقى]
م